>> HELLO AND WELCOME TO CONNECT
THE WORLD.
POLAND HAS GRANTED A
HUMANITARIAN VISA TO A
BELARUSIAN ATHLETE WHO REFUSED
TO BOARD A FLIGHT TO HER HOME
COUNTRY.
ATHLETE KRYSTYNA IS IN THE
POLAND EMBASSY AT THIS HOUR
AFTER SHE CRITICIZED HER COACHES
FOR BEING ENTERED INTO THE 4
400 RELAY WITHOUT HER CONSENT.
SHE REPORTEDLY ASKED FOR HELP AT
TOKYO'S AIRPORT WHEN TEAM
OFFICIALS TRIED TO SEND HER
HOME.
ON SUNDAY, THE ATHLETE TOLD A
REPORTER SHE BELIEVES SHE WILL
BE PUT IN JAIL IF SHE GOES BACK
TO BELARUS.
WE ARE COVERING THIS STORY ON
TWO CONTINENTS.
NICK PATON WALSH STANDING BY IN
LONDON.
SELINA WANG IS JOINING US FROM
TOKYO FIRST UP.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THIS CASE AT
THIS POINT?
>> WELL, BECKY, I'M STANDING
OUTSIDE THE POLISH EMBASSY HERE
IN TOKYO WHERE KRISTINA
TIMANOSKAYA HAS ENTERED.
SHE HAS RECEIVED A HUMANITARIAN
VISA FROM POLAND.
THE DEPUTY MINISTER SAID THEY
WILL DO WHATEVER SHE CAN TO
CONTINUE HER SPORTING CAREER.
SHE WILL BE TRAVELING TO POLAND
IN THE COMING DAYS.
BECKY, SHE WAS SET TO COMPETE IN
THE 200 METER HEATS ON MONDAY.
SUNDAY, BELARUS TEAM
REPRESENTATIVES WENT TO THE
OLYMPIC VILLAGE, TOLD HER TO
PACK UP HER BELONGINGS AND GO
BACK TO BELARUS.
SHE GOT TO THE AIRPORT IN JAPAN,
APPROACHED JAPANESE POLICE
OFFICERS AND SAID SHE WANTED TO
SEEK POLITICAL ASYLUM AND FEARED
GOING BACK.
THIS FEAR COMES AFTER SHE SPOKE
OUT AGAINST NATIONAL SPORTING
AUTHORITIES, COMPLAINING ON
INSTAGRAM SHE HAD BEEN ENTERED
INTO THIS 4 X 400 RELAY, WHICH
SHE HAD NOT PREPARED FOR.
IT WAS WITHOUT HER CONSENT.
THIS IS WHAT SHE SAID TO A
BELARUS SPORT SITE.
I AM AFRAID THAT I MIGHT BE
JAILED IN BELARUS.
I AM NOT AFRAID OF BEING FIRED
OR KICKED OUT OF THE NATIONAL
TEAM.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT MY SAFETY
AND I THINK AT THE MOMENT IT IS
NOT SAFE FOR ME IN BELARUS.
I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING.
BUT THEY DEPRIVED ME OF THE
RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
200-METER RACE AND WANTED TO
SEND ME HOME.
NOW, BECKY, BELARUSIAN ATHLETES
WHO CRITICIZED THE GOVERNMENT
AFTER PROTESTS HAVE BEEN
EXCLUDED FROM OLYMPIC GAMES.
LUCHLT KASHENKO HAS CRACKDOWNS.
SOME ATHLETES WHO PARTICIPATED
IN THE PROTESTS HAVE BEEN
JAILED.
LUKASHENKO HAS BEEN IN CHARGE
OF THE OLYMPIC COMMITTEE IN
BELARUS FOR DAYS BEFORE HIS SON
TOOK OVER.
IOC DOES NOT RECOGNIZE HER SON
VIKTOR AND HE AND HIS SON ARE
BANNED FROM ATTENDING THE GAMES.
BECKY?
>> NICK PATON WALSH IS
CONNECTING YOU WITH THE DETAILS
FROM LONDON.
LET'S START WITH POLAND.
WHAT IS POLAND SAYING ABOUT WHAT
IS GOING ON?
>> ESSENTIALLY POLAND, ALONG
WITH THE OTHER EU STATES IS
WATCHING THIS SLOW MOTION CAR
CRASH OF AUTHORITARIANISM ACROSS
THE BORDER OVER THE PAST YEAR OR
SO NOW.
WE'VE SEEN EXTRAORDINARY
BRUTALITY ON THE BEHALF OF RIOT
POLICE AGAINST ENTIRELY PEACEFUL
VERY YOUNG BELARUSIAN CITIZENS,
ALLED BY POLICE USING BATONS
AND EERIE PICTURES THE
GOVERNMENT HIMSELF RELEASED OF A
PROTESTER DYING IN POLICE
CUSTODY.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE HAVE
LEFT THAT COUNTRY, MANY OF THEM
INTO POLAND.
POLAND'S POSITION ON THIS, I
THINK, IS TWO-FOLD.
IT SEES AS A MEMBER OF THE
EUROPEAN UNION TO GIVE ASYLUM.
NO LOVE LOST BETWEEN THEM AND
THE LUKASHENKO REGIME AND
GOVERNMENT.
THOSE LEAVING ARE THE BETTER
EDUCATED, INTERNET-SAVVY,
HARDWORKING BELARUSIANS WHO SEEK
A MORE WESTERN-STYLE SOCIETY
INSIDE BELARUS AND MAKE A
SUBSTANTIAL CONTRIBUTION TO
POLAND'S ECONOMY.
WE'RE SEEING THIS OF ALL THE EU
NEIGHBORS OF BELARUS.
BRIGHT, YOUNG BELARUSIANS
LEAVING, STARTING A LIFE FOR
THEMSELVES ELSEWHERE AND TRYING
TO KEEP WHAT THEY CAN OF THE
PROTEST MOVEMENT INSIDE.
IT HAS BEEN SO HEAVILY HIT NOW,
SO MUCH OF THE PROTESTS OF WHAT
YOU SEE IS ESSENTIALLY FLASH
MOBS THAT BRIEFLY APPEAR, AND
PUT THEIR POE TESTS ON LINE.
REAL CONCERNS OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING OFF CAMERA TO PEOPLE
LIKE KRISTINA TIMANOVSKAYA,S WHO
PLIGHT IS NOT REPORTED ON ACROSS
THE WORLD AND HAVING AN
EXCEPTIONAL BRUTAL TIME IN
CUSTODY.
BECKY?
>> HOW WILL THIS AFFECT
RELATIONS BETWEEN POLAND AND THE
WIDER EU AND THE COUNTRY?
>> YEAH.
THE STATEMENT SO FAR, AS I'M
AWARE, FROM THE BELARUSIAN
OLYMPIC COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO
HAVE BEEN CLEAR.
THEY BELIEVE MISS TIMANOVSKAYA
HAD EMOTIONAL OR PSYCHOLOGICAL
ISSUES AND THAT'S WHY THEY TOOK
HER OFF THE TEAM.
FOR THOSE WHO GREW UP IN THE
FORMER SOVIET UNION, THE USE OF
A PSYCHOLOGICAL REASON FOR
SOMEONE TO FORCE SOMEONE BACK TO
THEIR COUNTRY IS COMMON FOR THE
SOVIET UNION.
ACCORDING TO MISS TIMANOVSKAYA,
BEING FORCIBLY REPATRIATED YOU
WOULD EXPECT FROM NORTH KOREA OR
OPPRESSIVE REGIME.
THESE TACTICS HAVE BEEN USED BY
BELARUS, THE PRESIDENT CALLED
THE LAST DICTATOR IN EUROPE.
RELATIONSHIP WITH POLAND NEXT
DOOR OBVIOUSLY WILL DETERIORATE
BECAUSE OF POLAND'S OPEN EMBRACE
OF THE ATHLETE TIMANOVSKAYA.
SHE WILL GET A HUMANITARIAN VISA
AND LIKELY ASYLUM AND CONTINUE
HER SPORT FROM THAT COUNTRY,
TOO.
IT CONTINUES TO TIGHTEN THE NOOS
AROUND BELARUS' GOVERNMENT
THERE.
UNDER HEAVY SANCTIONS AFTER
TRYING TO GET AN INTERNATIONAL
BLOGGER OFF THAT PLANE.
LOT OF BACKING FROM MOSCOW.
THERE ARE TWO MINDS TO HOW
MOSCOW FEELS ABOUT THIS.
SOME ANALYSTS SAY MOSCOW IS
GRATEFUL OF THE DISTRACTION NEXT
DOOR IN BELARUS BECAUSE IT MAKES
THEM LOOK LIKE THE RESPONSIBLE
ADULT IN THE AUTHORITARIAN ROOM
AND OTHERS SAY RUSSIA COULD
SIMPLY DO WITHOUT THIS SORT OF
ATTENTION AND THIS SORT OF CHAOS
CONSTANTLY BEING FERMENTED BY
THEIR NEIGHBOR.
>> KRISTINA TIMANOVSKAYA DOES
NOT HAVE A REPUTATION AS AN
ACTIVIST OR BEING PARTICULARLY
CRITICAL OF THE GOVERNMENT.
THIS WAS A PERSONAL INSTAGRAM
POSTING CLEARLY OUT OF
FRUSTRATION AND THEN FEAR.
>> Reporter: YES, BECKY.
ACCORDING TO WHAT WE KNOW AND
WHAT SHE HAS SAID, SHE POSTED ON
INSTAGRAM, SIMPLY SPEAKING OUT
THAT THIS ACTION WAS TAKEN OUT
OF HER CONSENT.
THE DECISION TO PUT HER IN THIS
RACE WAS MADE BEHIND HER BACK
SHE SAID, COMPLAINING ABOUT
NEGLIGENCE OF THE COACHES, NOT
MAKING SOME GRAND POLITICAL
STATEMENT.
OF COURSE, THERE ARE OTHER
SCENARIOS WHERE AT OLYMPICS
ATHLETES IN THE PAST HAVE TRIED
TO DEFECT AT THESE GLOBAL
SPORTING EVENTS.
AS FAR AS WE KNOW, SHE WAS
SPEAKING OUT ABOUT THIS
PARTICUL